eric avec tous les plans a redit son
ossature tube le père a bâti
alors maintenant jacques on va jouer à
un jeu idiot comme d'habitude tous
récents je vais te donner des noms de
gens comme ça un peu comme le tir au
pigeon d'argile je vais les jeter en
l'air et tu vas me dire ce que tu en
penses
juhasz qui par exemple bien enfin pense
que du bien ça va bien bien vis-à-vis de
moi bien vis-à-vis de toi bien très bien
très bien
bah oui tout à fait faire le film quitte
à lancer et suis quitte à relancer donc
avec un taux bien plein romain lui donc
la seconde tremplin godard vient bien
toi payet revient tout le temps comme ça
bah écoute j'ai bien l'odeur moi aussi à
moi tu loues de sauter c'est la famille
dre je ne peux que l'associé concevoir
et chez drucker comme un monstre parce
que au moins les questions était idiote
et de ville toute façon je peux tu
tournes avec joue en ce moment je n'ai
pas le choix
qu'apple soit un super jeu l'est j'avais
dit que mathilda may on m'avait prévenu
qu'elle avait une poitrine gigantesque
elle prend l'avion non et je j'ai pas
tout blanc j'y connais pas grand chose
réelle comme tu le sais
j'ai trouvé ça j'ai trouvé tout à fait
normal et que c'est une très bonne
comédienne patrick bruel dans le même
film qui s'appelle beaux moments
sweetheart mais il s'appelle
l'inspecteur vad d'un film bien bien
antoine et chemise à fleurs antoine roy
il a bien fait de faire de la voile
ouais voilà fait donc dix bien dix mois
françoise hardy quoi
ben oui non bien pas bien jacques
lanzmann donc sachez revue ouais tu
regarde toi oui tu leur vie dans 45
tours il marche tout seul
ouais gainsbourg bah écoutes je crois
que là il est absent pour un poids
langue etc le c'est quand même le
parrain but vous étiez très dirigeants
m'avaient je veux pas faire le genre son
vélo c'était moi lise c'était un ami oui
face est un ami c'est un des rares
d'ailleurs deux par rapport à ce métier
claude françois c'est l'inconnu oui je
les ai connus maquiller et je les ai pas
reconnu démaquiller parce qu'un jeu il a
débarqué en corse me demander qu'est ce
que c'était que ce monsieur c'était lui
ses bras à vie mais lui c'est un pote on
s'est connus on devait avoir je sais pas
quel âge
14 en 13 ans à la trinité paris la
grande époque mais diminuer a prédit t
il été pareil il va pas changer lui
profondément non mais autour oui puisque
quand c'est mad max hillerman maths en
libye enfin il faillit lui les trucs
mais c'est un des rares qui même s'ils
se met au goût du jour il tournage est
un des rares qui est une présence et
celle à celle à coire c'est là est ce
que tu as connu c'est là c'est pareil il
est venu démontrer la caméra explore le
temps elle est venue dîner c'est ouais
elle adore le saucisson ouais
en parlant de 6 ans tu trouves pas
scandaleux les rumeurs qui ont couru sur
son compte
sheila est un homme ça c'était l'époque
on se faisait pas opéré oui maintenant
il ya plus de rumeurs il ya un truc à
part le test de féminité qui aurait
peut-être bien servir cheylard g